hallo mein name ist krieg und ich zeige
euch heute etwas in minecraft ich möchte
gerne am ende des videos noch mal kurz
ein kleines statement geben zu dem kanal
an sich und minecraft veränderungen und
blauen klub aber wir fangen jetzt erst
mal anderem mit dem was wir zeigen
möchte uns mal seht ihr hier schon die
welt godzilla bei ki moon volo wenn wir
da mal reingehen seht ihr schon spawnen
wir hier in sonnen raum ließ putin vw
between sixties seventies sounds laut
friendscout creatures mörder scs
creatures habe ich auf jeden fall schon
alles befolgt und hier steht noch des
labors created by team wo ludo
youtube.com / team hulu und wir sehen
hier drei ports das hier ist die rhi
commented merkt das ist nämlich einmal
die die stryker 2.0 dann haben wir noch
eine andere map das greenfield und wir
haben noch die map empire polis und ich
würde sagen wir gehen jetzt erst mal in
die membran 43 denn das ganze ist die
godzilla dem motte nicht wirklich
sondern ihr müsst euch quasi nur die
welt runterladen und damit habt ihr
quasi schon alles hier sind jetzt hier
in der welt drin und wir sind dieses
ziel china gewesen hier
bleib mal ruhig bitte godsilla wir
können hier toben laufen können ja alles
kaputt machen und wir haben hier auch
verschiedene items das heißt wir haben
hier beispielsweise scales priska rast
das heißt dies meistens dahin und ihr
seht schon ok was passiert hier
hier ist überall so flinten steals
beziehungsweise diese feuerstein und ihr
seht schon da wo die jetzt mich runter
fallen
seht ihr jeden moment fallen die dahin
und machen dort und kleinen radius wie
tnt in externe tnt explosion nur dass
dort dann halt doch so ein bisschen
feuer mit dazu kommt da seht ihr es und
das ist quasi das dieses geld macht dann
haben wir auch den seismik slam wenn ich
den fallenlassen seht ihr schon platz
fliegen wir quasi einmal kurz hoch und
lasst uns dann wieder fallen
und da wo wir uns fallen lassen kommt
dann in alle himmelsrichtungen sondern
fein raus wird zur feier tnt halterin
das auch gerade gesehen wir können noch
einfach mit godzilla hier beispielsweise
die häuser ganz simpel um laufen hier
kann man immer rumlaufen ich kann doch
einfach mal dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr anstellen damit wir so ein
bisschen näher an lindsey dran sind weil
der stand zwar mainka egal wer du bist
auch tot sondern mich in meinen reihen
laufen und wir gehören einfach alles
zerstören mit godzilla aber wir schauen
uns jetzt erstmal diesen feier beamer
und zwar wenn ich den fallen lassen wenn
ich den feiert ihn fallen lasse
und hier gleich mehr oder weniger sonnen
da sehen ist glaub ich schon als ich
meine das ist das schon oder einfach
dass er so feuer spuckt aber komische
sound das nächste items sammeln baby und
zwar wenn ich das fallen das seht ihr
schon genau das was quasi dieses auch
sagt da vorne drückt jetzt gerade dieses
baby und wir sehen jeden moment
es fällt um bis dahin eigentlich sollte
sein baby godzilla spawn jeden moment
fällt es um und es ist einfach tot
was soll das wieso ist das tot das kann
auch nicht
eigentlich sollte dann haben wir als
nächstes altem ideen lightning orbit und
zwar kommt dort ein blitz auf mich drauf
ich fange an zu brennen und überall sind
andere blitze und machen nahezu alles
kaputt also überall schlangen blitz ein
und lassen alles an
zu brennen wo die einen schlagen und
alles übels krass und wenn ich das halt
wieder stoppen will muss ich einfach
wieder den fall hinschmeißen und dann
seht ihr schon die blitze hören auf ich
höre auf zu brennen
das macht der leighton im orbit dann
haben wir zwei kabinen den habe ich noch
gar nicht getestet dann ärgert das sieht
nicht gut aus wenn ich hier geradezu am
schimmernden jedenfalls habe mit diesem
jetzt in hyper birgit charts und hiermit
können wir den jetzt aktivieren das
heißt wenn ich jetzt das ende august
fallen lasse die schon mal mama mama
beim überall hinfliegen tnt ist in dem
alter das sieht auf jeden fall nicht
sehr gesund für die brücke gerade aus
ihr wird auch schon dass ich dadurch
jetzt ein bisschen schneller geworden
bin also speed habe ich noch dazu
bekommen kann es dementsprechend ihr
noch ein bisschen schneller rum laufen
haben shampoos also ich kann noch ein
bisschen höher springen und hiermit
quasi alles kaputtmachen das letzte ist
ob surf wenn ich den fallen lasse habe
ich auch noch nicht getestet ob surf
live-act origin location jetzt bin ich
bin jetzt jedoch nicht ich bin frei von
godzilla ich bin jetzt quasi im game
mode zwei oder drei top game of game auf
jeden fall jedenfalls bin ich gerade in
dem und kann mich jetzt hier godzilla
anschauen und freunde da dies wenn ich
an somit einfach nicht mehr da aber das
ist auf jeden fall godzilla wenn wir
hier jetzt wieder in die welt
beispielsweise reingehen sehen wir schon
dass wir wieder an dem anfangspunkt sind
und uns jetzt noch eine andere app
aussuchen können das heißt wir nehmen
jetzt beispielsweise mal mike hooper 2.0
das ist ja die recommended map werden da
noch mal ein bisschen was kaputt machen
und danach möchte dann auch über ein
gewisses thema mit euch noch mal eben
reden hier sind wir jetzt quasi wirklich
in einer großstadt wohl das wirklich
noch mal sehen können was wir hiermit
alles kaputt machen können ich fahre
jetzt einfach mal so ein paar items die
ganze zeit hinter man das baby gorilla
da machen wir immer den lightning orbit
hyper hyper da und immer noch auf mit
dem orbit und die siegchance haben
innerhalb von kürzester zeit das
komplette haus zerstört da hinten ist
alles verstellt übels auch schon das
nächste hoch aus rein tut mir leid
freude hört sich das an
man hört einfach die fußstapfen von
godzilla und ich bin über dem gebäude
und unter mir macht er einfach gerade
alles kaputt alter in solchen momenten
des übels gearbeitet
in solchen momenten ist geil wenn
minecraft diese gravitations effekte
einfach drin hätte dass das jetzt
einfach alles ein krachen würde also wer
übels heftig also das ist auf jeden fall
die godzilla mod mehr oder weniger als
es halt eine map ihr findet den web
download in der beschreibung und dann
könnt ihr auch noch mal die dritte map
austesten und jetzt zu dem thema über
das noch ganz schnell eben reden wollte
am ende dieser folge und zwar
normalerweise ist ja immer der freitag
dieser minecraft commands tag gewesen
und das möchte ich auch gern weiter
behalten allerdings habt ihr jetzt auch
schon gemerkt das hier war kein
minecraft kommen und ich habe auch
damals vor zwei monaten mal schon mal
einen command vorgestellt sage ich mal
was eigentlich nur eine map war bzw
die sonne wandel an bord es geht einfach
darum dass ich will ganz ehrlich mit
euch sein das wisst ihr und mir macht
minecraft in letzter zeit nicht so viel
spaß wie einfach andere neue spiele zu
zocken und die cool zusammenzuschneiden
das habt ihr eventuell mit bekommen
dadurch dass jetzt clever bot serie habe
dass ich sehr viel ärger gemacht habe
dass ich so sachen machen werde wie oder
immer noch geht die ganze zeit gemacht
habe so andere kleinere spiele zocken
einfach zusammen schneiden das macht mir
einfach derzeit viel mehr spaß als mein
klar versteht mich nicht falsch
minecraft ist immer noch übelst geil ich
finde es auch cool solche sachen einfach
auszuprobieren minecraft ich glaube das
merkt man auch dass mir gerade diese
command so immer was neues hinzukommt
wiebels viel spaß machte minecraft nur
mein buch was jetzt auch im 24
september rauskommen wird also in
zeckern im monat handelt auch nahezu nur
über minecraft aber ich will für mich
selbst halt immer so ein bisschen
abwechslung und was neues ausprobieren
und deswegen möchte ich euch einfach
sagen freitags wird der tag bleiben wo
immer in der woche minecraft kommt das
können minecraft command sein
das kann auch mal sowas sein die sonne
godzilla motto welt in etwa also
freitags wird es wöchentlich immer
minecraft geben aber an vielleicht auch
an anderen tagen aber freitags wird zu
bleiben minecraft aber es wird kein
kommentar sein das heißt es kann aber
sein dass freitag so was kommt was
einfach eine welt ist
anstatt command sag ich mal das wollte
ich nur sagen weil nicht dass jetzt
einige meinen ja freitag von marco
martens tag und wieso kommt denn jetzt
eine map ja habe ich ja gerade erklärt
freitags ist minecraft tag jetzt auf
meinem kanal sonst was gibt es noch zu
sagen wo ich jetzt gerade hier im land
wenn ja es gibt ja dieses tube
gleichzeitig bin halt wirklich kein fan
davon dass sich immer einen link täglich
bei twitter post oder so dann eher wenig
sie beim ende des videos oder so wenn
ihr wollt ist der typ flash dabei wenn
findet ihren link in der beschreibung
und sonst wenn euch das video gefallen
hat würde ich mich definitiv bei der
bewertung freuen und wir sehen uns dann
morgen in einer neuen serie wieder die
wieder total behindert und witzig wird
also unbedingt auf morgen freundschaft